[Musique]
les associations avaient appelé à
pratiquer le chemin ouvert seulement ce
matin si les barrières étaient toujours
à terre elle était remplacée par une
barrière humaine une importante présence
de gendarmerie pour simon il tord à la
terrible voudrait qu'à passer rigoler
mais aujourd'hui a quand même aux us
d'amendé ition la plage est loucas
constatait que saab était assez mon blog
il a campé celle où base et les
manifestants pouces et réclame un arrêté
préfectoral d'interdiction de circuler
la sous préfecture dit vouloir éviter
les affrontements
les uns disent oui mais on veut accéder
au littoral ont dit oui on va rétablir
ce fax au littoral mais aujourd'hui on
est sur des propriétés privées
la semaine dernière il ya eu des
exactions il ya des habitants qui sont
effrayés ils nous l'ont dit donc il faut
qu'on arrive à trouver le bon compromis
pour travailler tous ensemble mais
rétablir un cadre de sorin pour qu'on
n'ait pas des gens qui vont saccager
d'un côté ou des gens qui soient
effrayés l'eau une délégation de 25
personnes a bien été autorisés à passer
en compagnie de la sous préfète
elle a pu constater que les accès
étaient toujours ouverts la sopa marc
connaît bien le terrain pour avoir mené
une opération similaire en 2007
mais aujourd'hui tout le monde n'était
pas sur la même longueur d'onde coma de
toute négociation et nier ça aucun
modèle des centres ap nous estimons que
nos délégations de passer outre constaté
qu'en s'acquitter de bernier pas libéré
s'achète un baiia positif
est-ce qu'à nîmes initiatique au sein
mais là les aléas qui fait la différence
bien que ça nous constatons nous
constaté que la plupart assez barrier a
quitté le toujours à terre les membres
de l'association monde qui avait refusé
la délégation passe par la mer et
reviennent par le même chemin pour
annoncer la suite des opérations
pour nous pas aller d'autres auteurs
imaginent et robert rocca di nou camp il
ya 16 innocentes des mères mais comme
nous sommes que j'adore leurs amis donc
idiot hawkeye en effet un petit peu plus
à sainte-luce des réunions entre la
préfecture la d aller les associations
devraient permettre d'étudier une
solution avec un projet présenté sous 15
jours